police in Hong Kong are trying to break
up more protests it's the 24th straight
weekend of unrest and anger at security
forces is growing demonstrations started
against a bill that would allow
extradition to China that's been shelved
but anti-government sentiment continues
to spread Sarah Clark is joining us from
Hong Kong and you're at a vigil in the
central part of the city what are you
seeing there Sarah well this is a vigil
to remember the 22 year old student who
died on Friday this week called last
week I should say I have to be involved
in a protest on early Monday morning
here in Hong Kong he fell from a car
park I had a brain injury and on Friday
after two operations he had a cardiac
arrest and died now this is a one
particular there's about 200 or so
people here are paying tribute to that
student with that protester but
throughout Sunday there's been six
districts targeted by those protests the
protest movement and they focused on the
shopping centers the shopping malls and
mtrs
I was doing a couple of confrontations
between police in two areas two one and
two and one where we were in shouting
now we had a number of protesters damage
stores the MTR and smashed glass at
those shopping centers and now the
police presence has been quite heavy
across the city today simply because
they're targeting those six districts
and this evening on Sunday something
nice they've also got a second phase of
shopping centres being are being
targeted or focused on and I should say
on Monday the protest movement is
encouraging a general strike that
general strike will be the people
targeting the transport various
transport systems including the MTR
which is the train system here as well
as roads and they're calling it a
general strike simply because they're
trying to stop people are getting to
work on time on Monday so as you
mentioned this is now the fifth month of
protests here in Hong Kong and Sarah an
international independent excuse me
international panel investigating Hong
Kong's police watchdog in its ability to
investigate the forces now released an
interim report which is critical of the
watchdog what more has the report says
well this is certainly an interesting
development the government's out this
International Panel to support or work
with Hong Kong's watchdog
- an investigation entity's ongoing
protests and the interim report the
progress report was released by Twitter
and by one of the panelists there
professor Clifford Stott from kill
University in the United Kingdom and
that particular report said that the
Hong Kong's watchdog the body lacks
power and the body must enhance its
power and its capability if they're
going to deliver a proper report into
your investigation into the ongoing
protests it said the body had a light
touch and it was an oversight body and
he also questioned how it can make this
comprehensive assessment and said that
the watchdog must revise its resources
and processes but no connection the
interesting development was how it was
released this was released on Twitter
and by this particular panelists so
again the government hasn't responded to
that and this is an interim report but
certainly having a panel an
international panel critical of Hong
Kong's watchdog is an interesting
development in his ongoing protests
Sarah Clark thank you